Almost every Android app has
to open third party content
at some point.
At that moment,
developers need to decide
if they open that content in
the browser or use a web view.
Opening links in the browser
is a heavyweight transition
from the application and doesn't
allow you to customize the UI.
This may frustrate
users and make it harder
for them to return to your app.
Using a web view gives you
more control of the UI,
but it's harder to
build and doesn't
include all the cool features
that browser developers work
hard to provide.
Wouldn't it be nice if you could
have the best of both worlds?
That's why we created
Chrome Custom Tabs.
My name is Andre Bandarra,
and with Chrome Custom Tabs,
third party content in your
app is a first class citizen.
Chrome Custom Tabs is a new
way to show third party content
on Android.
It allows you to change
how Chrome looks and feels,
making the transition
from app to web seamless.
By using Custom Tabs,
you can customize
Chrome to match your application
color, change the start
and exit animations, or add a
custom action to the toolbar,
like a button to save an
article to read later.
It also features a
customizable Up button
that makes it
easier for the user
to return to your app once
done with the content.
Being a part of Chrome, it
shares the same cookie jar
so your users won't have
to log in frequently
to view third part content.
It also makes it easier
for the content publishers
to track user engagement
coming from your application.
You also get the Chrome features
like form autofill, geolocation
prompts, and page translation.
But it's also about speed
as it allows your app
to ask Chrome to preload
content in the background
so that when users click on a
link, it will open really fast.
Preloading content
can make the links
inside your at open up
to three times faster
than using a normal
Chrome tab or web view.
Chrome Custom Tabs
is already available
starting from Chrome version 45.
Let's take a look at
how to use Chrome Custom
Tabs in your Android app.
First, add the Android Support
Library to your project
build file.
To enable warm up
and preloading,
you need to connect
to browser service.
Once connected, you can
ask Chrome to warm up.
To prefetch the contents,
create a new navigation session,
optionally passing a callback.
Now you are ready to ask Chrome
to prefetch the third party
content.
You can give it a single
URL, or if you need more,
you can add a list of other URLs
the user is likely to navigate.
Chrome will prioritize
the first URL
followed by all other URLs on
the list in the order passed
to it.
And don't forget to unbind
the service when Chrome Custom
Tabs is no longer needed.
Now if possible, Chrome will
start to prefetch the content.
It may go all the
way from resolving
DNS to fetching the page and
support content like CSS,
JavaScript, and images, and
even prerender the page up
to the point that
all that remains
is to actually draw the
pixels on the screen.
You open a Chrome Tab by
using a custom tab Intent.
Pass it a reference to the
host activity and the URI
you want to open.
If the URI matches, one of the
URIs [INAUDIBLE] prefetching,
Chrome will use
prefetched contents.
Otherwise, it will fetch and
render the page at that moment.
There are various customizations
possible in the Custom Tab UI.
Use them by calling the
corresponding methods
on the Custom Tabs
Intent Builder.
To change the application
bar color for instance,
you need to call the
setToolbarColor methods.
Chrome Custom Tabs
is a powerful tool
that allows your
application to open
web content in a seamless way.
By using it, you get the UI
flexibility of a web view,
increase the user retention,
and create a seamless transition
between your app and the web.
You also get a shared
cookie jar, form autofill,
and all the other cool
features from Chrome,
improving even more
the user experience
and providing better metrics
for content publishers.
It also has the unique
advantage of being
able to prefetch the content,
making it load faster.
All those features make
it the best solution
when opening third party
content in your application.
It's also an open
specification, which
means that other browsers
besides Chrome is supported.
If you want to see how to
integrate Chrome Custom
Tabs in your Android app,
check out them on GitHub.
Or if you have questions,
you can send them
on the Stack Overflow
tag chrome-custom-tabs.
Next time you want third
party content in your app,
let Chrome pick up the tab.
[MUSIC PLAYING]